weltweit empörung über novak djokovic
den ungeimpften den regelbrecher hast
beschimpfungen das ard magazin extra 3
rät ihm sogar sich schon mal
ohrenschützer zu kaufen weil er ab jetzt
ausgebucht werde aber sind
möglicherweise die regel die falschen
darüber diskutiere ich jetzt mit ihm
selbst mal weltklasse tennisspieler
michael stich und mit ihm dem corona
regel kritiker und journalisten team
rücken
achtung ist dieser mann wirklich eine
gefahr für ihre gesundheit novak
djokovic topfit völlig durchtrainiert ja
er ist eine gefahr für das
gesundheitssystem sagt stephen nolan
bbc-journalist der so aussieht die
moderatorin einer australischen
nachrichtensendung sind sich deshalb
völlig einig war es novak djokovic für
sie ist
die nacht
so denken die also über den regelbrecher
novak djokovic dort in dieser
australischen nachrichtensendung das all
dem magazin extra 3 hier in deutschland
empfiehlt nur was djokovic sommer sich
so ohrenschützer zu kaufen gegen die
gellenden pfiffe gegen die ganzen
buhrufe die ihn jetzt erwarten werden
und der spiegel der warnt sogar davor
dass ab jetzt jedes match von novak
djokovic jeder sieg von ihm ein schatten
werfe auf den kompletten sport darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit einem mann dem ich
besonders gerne zugeschaut habe beim
tennisspiel für den ich damals nachts
aufgestanden bin zu den australian open
um ihm beim siegen zu zuschauern michael
stich ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet bei
bild er mittlerweile neuen podcast tat
mit seinem damaligen tennispartner mit
patrik kühnen schönen guten tag herr
stich einen wunderschönen tag also
würden sie aktuell heute mit dem
ungeimpften novak djokovic auf den platz
gehen zum tennisspielen ach ja wenn er
getestet wäre und jeden tag pcr test
hätte man wüsste dass er nicht infiziert
ist hätte ich da keine sorgen weil der
abstand im tennisplatz ist doch relativ
groß also von daher hängt ist ja nicht
nur vom umkämpft sein ab und die meisten
von ihnen bzw
der kollegen von novak djokovic habe ich
moment den eindruck wollen ihn sowieso
nicht so gern umarmen deswegen die frage
stellt sich ja ich glaube die meisten
würden zu antworten wie sie aktuell der
aktiven tennis profis warum soll er denn
nicht verspielen er war das natürlich
regeln gibt die erlassen worden sind um
genau den australien auch gerecht zu
werden und des problems natürlich dass
die regeln anscheinend nicht so klar
waren dass jeder genau wusste woran er
sich zu halten hat oder es wusste jeder
und es gibt menschen die sich nicht
daran gehalten haben und das ist ja
genau die frage die jetzt gerade immer
wieder gestellt wird er stellt als nicht
kämpft natürlich trotzdem ein größeres
risiko da das ist ganz klar und so weit
ich gelesen habe plan die austrian open
ja auch mit vollen zuschauerrängen dort
zu spielen und dann geld natürlich für
alle zuschauer sicherheit ganz gerade
regeln wann man nur rein darf und das
sollte natürlich dann auch für jeden
einzelnen spieler geld also ist novak
djokovic dadurch dass er nicht geimpft
ist eine gefahr ist eine größere gefahr
auch jeder geimpfte wie wir wissen kann
sich heute infizieren und kann dann auch
wieder ein überträger sein und eine
gefahr darstellen aber ein umkämpfter
stellt eine größere gefahr da weil er
sich leichter infizieren kann und weil
er auch mehr viren wiederum weitergeben
kann aber ich glaube auch dass die
diskussion gar nicht mehr um umgehend
gefahren nicht gefahr es geht ums
prinzip es gab regeln man hat sich so
wie man das verfolgen kann nicht an
diese regeln gehalten ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass der aus der tennis
australia gesagt hätte bei uns dürfen
nur geimpfte spieler spielen dann hätte
es diese diskussion überhaupt nicht
gegeben aber wenn es nur noch ums
prinzip geht kann man ja noch einmal
fragen ob das prinzip überhaupt stimmt
ob die regeln überhaupt stimmen naja die
regeln sind da und ich glaube jetzt die
regeln zu hinterfragen ist würde
wiederum einen schritt zu weit gehen ich
finde ja ich finde dass es darum geht
die menschen im besten möglichst im
falle zu schützen wir können
grundsätzlich nie etwas ausschließen
dass etwas passiert aber man kann
versuchen die risikominimierung
voranzutreiben und dazu gehört es besten
falle dass man geimpft ist dass man sich
jeden tag testen lässt aber das gibt es
ja bei anderen sport großereignissen
auch dass da auch nicht ganz klar ist
wie dann die sicherheit der athleten
aber auch der zuschauer gewährleistet
werden soll wünschen sie novak djokovic
jetzt den turniersieg feiern australian
open air ähnlicher weise ist mir das
völlig egal
ich habe keine enge beziehung zu novak
djokovic
dass die zuschauer da sehr schwarz weiß
sein werden ist auch ganz klar nur ich
glauben wohl eine sache trennen norbert
j tennisspieler genießt von allen seiten
in allerhöchsten respekt und für seine
erfolge kann man ihn nur feiern da gibt
es überhaupt gar keine einschränkung
aber jetzt geht es nicht um mein
tennisspiel jetzt geht es um den
menschen novak djokovic in der
vergangenheit schon polarisiert hat und
man muss mit der konsequenz seines
polarisierenden handelns auch leben
können und damit muss er sich
auseinandersetzen oder wird negative
sowie positive reaktion einzuordnen
haben und was immer daraus macht ob wie
das beeinflusst sein spiel oder nicht
wage ich nicht zu beurteilen
ich weiß mich hätte es beeinflusst aber
vielleicht ist er da wesentlich
abgebrühter sie haben den typen novak
djokovic und angesprochen über den haben
sich ja vorher auch schon viel mehr
geärgert über einzelne äußerungen von
ihm über vielleicht eine
grundeinstellung erst ein besonderer typ
was ernährung was gesundheit angeht
sowieso den muss man ja nicht folgen
aber bisher konnte man sagen ja gut das
ist der novak djokovic warum macht man
das hier nicht ganz genau so dass man
sagt er kommen das kriegen wir halt
jetzt nicht hin dass der sich impfen
lässt aber das können wir schon ertragen
von gc nicht man hat ja akzeptiert dass
es in jedem zulässt und das respektiere
ich auch absolut das ist seine
entscheidung es ist sein körper wenn ich
das nicht tue das ist wie bei uns im
land wenn ich nicht gewinnen dann muss
ich halt eine maske tragen test machen
und jeder daran sagt ich möchte aber
keine maske tragen kann es machen dann
muss man sich impfen lassen weil es gibt
halt regeln das ist so wie wenn ich
jetzt auto einsteigen ich möchte dann
ohne sicherheitsgurt fahren das darf ich
auch nicht weil wenn ich tue und
erwischt werde muss ich eine strafe
bezahlen und so ist hier also es geht
nicht mehr um das thema impfen oder
nicht impfen es geht darum hat er sich
an die regeln gehalten um eine
ausnahmegenehmigung zu bekommen und das
ist ja die diskussion die geführt wird
danke herr stich letzter tipp wie weit
kommt nur weil djokovic wenn er den
spielen darf bei den australian open in
diesem jahr ich glaube darf nicht
spielen
vielen dank für die prognose schlechte
prognose hörst dich vielen dank für das
gespräch übergeben
ist ab jetzt jedes match dass novak
djokovic gewinnt eine niederlage eine
gefahr für die komplette corona politik
den eindruck gewinnt man doch dass der
ab jetzt kein spiel mehr gewinnen soll
der novak djokovic der spiegel hat
vorsichtshalber schon mal sein
investigativ team auf ihn angesetzt um
zu überprüfen ob seine corona tests
richtig sind ob er getrickst hat
betrogen hat damit man ihn überführen
kann den novak djokovic damit auf keinen
fall spielen darf bei den australian
open
spitzensport also nur für geimpfte
weltrangliste nur für geimpfte sieht so
unser sportler aus olympische spiele zum
beispiel nur für geimpfte
ausgetragen organisiert von einem
brutalen regime in china eingeladen alle
anderen brutalen regimes dieser welt
aber ungeimpfte die müssen dann draußen
bleiben oder die fußball wm in katar
auch sie organisiert von dem regime mit
dem wir nichts zu tun haben wollen
eingeladen die ganze fußballwelt außer
ungeimpfte die müssen draußen bleiben
sind das die regeln wirklich an die wir
glauben
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit dem
journalisten tim röhn schönen guten tag
herr höhn ich grüße sie herr weise
erholen was halten sie aktuell für
gefährlicher für ihre gesundheit für die
gesellschaft novak djokovic oder die
corinna regeln
na ja das ist eine gute frage ich würde
mal behaupten eine negativ getesteter
novak djokovic kann für die gesundheit
ein nicht allzu großes problem
darstellen ehrlich gesagt und wenn ich
mir die globale pandemie bekämpfung
anschaue in den vergangenen zwei jahren
dann ist das doch eher die politik dem
er etwas mehr sorgen bereitet als die
gefahr die von diesem tennisspieler
ausgeht aber wir hören in den letzten
tagen immer wieder vor allen dingen in
deutschland hier das argument man der
muss sich an die regeln halten genau wie
sich alle anderen auch an die regeln
halten müssen ja also ich denke man muss
sich auch an die regeln halten man kann
weder ein impfpass fälschen noch einen
test fälschen noch sonst irgendetwas in
diese richtung tun er hat diese regeln
zu akzeptieren
nichtsdestotrotz denke ich dass man auch
einmal einen schritt zurückgehen sollte
brauchen wir diese regeln wirklich in
dieser form omikron gerade zeigt uns
dass corona deutlich ungefährlicher
geworden ist wir reden ja auch darüber
dass eine ein test vorgeschrieben ist
also wirklich so weit gehen die regel
dauerhaft zu etablieren nur noch gegen
korona geimpfte im reisen zu lassen und
daran kann man ja auch die frage
anknüpfen wie oft soll denn diese leute
geimpft sein wenn sie reisen wollen das
lässt sich ja zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
auch noch überhaupt nicht sagen was ist
denn ihre antwort auf diese frage ich
denke das ist nachvollziehbar ist dass
man im globalen reiseverkehr aktuell auf
pcr-test avanti gentest setzt aber nur
geimpfte reifen zu lassen wo völlig klar
ist mittlerweile als recht durch omikron
dass auch geimpfte das virus übertragen
können und so wie es jetzt aussieht im
blick auf die europäischen instanzen
genauso übertragen sogar halte ich diese
vorstellung diese regel nur geimpfte
reisen zu lassen für relativ sinnlos
dieser fall djokovic nicht nur aber auch
dieser fall djokovic ist er jetzt ein
gewaltiger test wie reagieren wir darauf
was wollen wir eigentlich in unserer
gesellschaft in diesem corona ja wie
wird das ausgehen wie wird dieses jahr
weitergehen mit blick auf regeln und
freiheit ich glaube dass gerade die
weichen gestellt werden für dieses jahr
2022 wie werden wir in diesem jahr leben
ich denke das wird in diesen tagen und
wochen entschieden wenn man auf dem
standpunkt bleibt jede infektion
promikon delta oder alpha verhindern zu
wollen dann wird man aus dieser lok
staunt locker und spirale nicht
rauskommen wenn man sagt wir akzeptieren
das natürlich existieren der risiko das
mit einer micon infektion einher geht
dann wird man sich öffnen können ich
glaube das ist gerade die frage die in
die sich viele regierungen weltweit
stellen und stellen müssen können wir so
weitermachen oder müssen wir dann doch
sagen freedom day wenn sie gegen novak
djokovic zum match antreten
ja ich würde mit sicherheit gegen novak
djokovic zum zum bachelor antreten
würdigen danach noch die hand schütteln
ich denke wir sollten es in sachen angst
auch nicht übertreiben ich würde es auch
tun damit ginge ehrlicherweise ein traum
in erfüllung er wird es leider
wahrscheinlich absagen dieses match
danke schön für das gespräch danke
erweise
eine ganze woche lang hat sich die welt
jetzt aufgeregt sich empört über diesen
novak djokovic ein mann der es einem
zugegeben nicht immer so ganz leicht
macht ihn wirklich zu mögen aber nur was
djokovic den können wir doch auch wenn
er nicht geimpfte es einfach aushalten
in ertragen mit dem finger zu zeigen auf
coroner regelbrecher das ist doch
sinnlos das ist doch unnützes haben zu
viele von uns jetzt zu lange getan ein
einzelner top fitter super gesunder
tennis da der ist doch keine gefahr für
unser aller gesundheit für unser
zusammenleben unseren zusammenhalt
einzelne coroner regeln aber die sind es